[Music]
God wasn't known for being the most
forgiving game but there's nothing quite
like shanking your ball into the drink
or pond that's where this guy comes in
here at TPC Sawgrass hundreds of golfers
lose their balls to the infamous par-3
17th hole but one golfers misery is
another man's gold this is gordon davis
my name is Gordon Davis and I'm a
professional golf ball diver he makes a
living diving for golf balls all over
Florida other divers but golf balls
approximately 50 years there are a lot
of bones to be found on average I've
when I'm diving
I'll pick up three to four thousand
three or four thousand three or four
thousand whoa so how do you find these
golf balls
it's mostly you know just feel picking
them up out of the mud and some places
much too deep that you can't do nothing
with it you know and it's that mud that
makes it impossible to see well anything
most courses they very few that if it
has clear water most of them poor
visibility because of the algae and all
that so what happens next after I pull
the balls out they go through pick out
some of them and they take them from
there they being someone who wants to
repurpose these balls these balls are
authentic these authentic balls are
diced up placed in all sorts of usable
keepsakes like cufflinks watches and
bottle openers and Gordon he knows what
it takes to be a professional golf ball
diver well I tell people you got to be a
kind of a special cat to be a golf ball
diver somebody was grit and it wants to
be independent person it's luckily any
other business someone has to do it
everybody has a different job and this
is having to be Ryan
seeing as you're kind of a special cat
any advice for golfers trying to keep
their balls drive yeah take up another
sport
[Music]
hole-in-one there's something about
standing on stage and thinking about the
people that have doubted me in the past
standing on stage and thinking about the
people who I would say hello to and they
would just look at me and keep on
walking it's in that moment where I'm on
stage where none of that matter where
people see me as more than just a
janitor
I am Kenan Kyle's I am an
internationally touring opera singer I
performed it in Lincoln Center in
Carnegie Hall and the Chicago theater
and all these amazing venues but at the
end of the day in order to support those
dreams and support my life I am a
janitor I am a janitor because bills are
something that is very real and as you
get older they get bigger the
assumptions that people have about
janitors are that they are uneducated
impoverished I cannot tell you how many
looks I've got it and the side eyes
because they just think that all you're
just a janitor it's so interesting
because they never took the time to
really know who this person is that is
cleaning up after them being an opera
singer is very hard it's not easy
technically because opera music is very
complex
I meet with my vocal coach / mentor once
or twice a week but I myself rehearse
probably two hours on top of that a day
I am currently rehearsing this lead role
of Rigoletto for the client opera
group's production in Scotland we're
gonna let those my first title role
which makes this moment so amazing for
me because the whole opera is about him
and his story coming from being a
janitor to starring in a show is very
empowering being a janitor has humbled
me and has grounded me so much you have
to hold on to yourself because nobody
cares about your dreams more than you
did
[Music]
[Applause]
I've been told that there's no spot for
a woman in this sport I've been
physically assaulted in the cage but I
didn't let any of that stop me
sometimes the fight is outside of the
Ring
[Music]
I'm squeezie Valentine and I'm the first
and only cut woman in MMA what we do is
we rap the fighters hands before they
fight and do we take care of them
between rounds if there's any bleeding
we stop there's any swelling we take it
away pretty much the cut man motto is to
give them that one round that they
needed to win
[Applause]
I saw my first live MMA fight
and it was just such a cool experience
and I wanted to be a part of that arena
as much as I could I talked to the
promoter and asked him what jobs there
were he told me that my option was to be
a ring girl I had to wear the tiniest
string bikini
it was super uncomfortable to be wearing
that in front of all these people
that was not a fit for me
I saw the sliders getting her hands
wrapped and I immediately got
butterflies in my stomach and I knew
that was what I was supposed to be a
part of I would drive 60 miles one way
to gyms and I would voluntarily sit
there and rap fighters hands for their
sparring sessions just a sacrifice of
doing it for so long without getting any
income out of it was really really hard
I was a single mother of two young boys
and still trying to be a cut woman
rapping hands is more than just putting
gauze around a hand if you do not wrap a
fighter's hands correctly then their
hands will break you need to wrap
hundreds and hundreds of hands to be
considered great I brought my kids hands
around my pears hands I wrapped my
friends hands I would wrap as many hands
as I could possibly find it took me
years to feel like I got it down
[Music]
my first paying gig was wsof world
series of fighting in 2010 after four
years of doing it for free in 2014 I was
added to the roster of UFC come in UFC
is the Ultimate Fighting Championship it
is the most famous stage in the world
it's like the Olympics of MMA and now I
travel all over the world being a cut
woman for the UFC during my journey of
being a woman I had a lot of ups and
downs my kids are a huge reason why I do
all this they can see me you know not
giving up and in the end hitting my goal
and that's what carried me through 10
years of it you know it's just that
desire inside of like going to going
I understand what the fighter has to go
through to get into the cage we both had
to fight to get our spot in the ring
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there's a certain feeling of adrenaline
once you get up there in the air
it's a feeling unlike any other you feel
power you feel like you're in control
you feel special
that's what makes chappies beautiful
that's what makes the circus beautiful
[Music]
my name is Kristen Finlay and I'm a
trapeze artist
15 years ago I was working for a brewery
in Los Angeles I had a great life making
great money that had you know my Lexus
and I had a house I was only you know
twenty four years old a friend of mine
told me that she was flying trapeze and
I said what are you doing I want to come
watch I ended up taking a class and I
was hooked it was addictive ride away
and I'd quit my life in LA and I joined
the circus
I went from good paid to zero pay just
had to give everything up pretty much
overnight and here we are 15 years later
I never looked back and I've been on the
road ever since to run away and join the
circus it takes commitment you have to
be ready for anything you have to kind
of live on your toes because you never
know what's gonna happen your own
personal space your RV or whatever
that's your home and that's what has to
be stable inside whenever you're flying
trapeze you have to focus on what you're
doing and the moment you doubt yourself
in the middle of a trick most likely
you're going to mess up you're not going
to make it
the fact that I was able to do it made
it more appealing to me and I'm doing
these tricks and they're harder and
they're harder and this is awesome
whatever you want to do in your wildest
dreams do it
anything's possible there's not too many
african-american female circus
performers but I was still able to do it
your life is what you make of it and I
wouldn't change my life for the world I
really wouldn't
[Music]